And, again, this is Dr. Kevin Connors, that's my little bug down in the left-hand quarter
of that slide.
We're going to be talking about apoptosis.
If you follow me through this series so far, this is apoptosis, 301, the third in the
series of our little short classes, on the mechanisms of apoptosis, though.
Apoptosis is normal, programmed cell death, and we went over the difference between apoptosis,
normal cell death, a cell, and the process, which is basically a cell being murdered.
So this is apoptosis is what should take place.
It is not taking place with a cancer patient.
So if you have cancer, those cancer cells are not going through normal apoptosis.
That is step one and how to get cancer.
Don't have your cells go through apoptosis, and it typically starts with just one singular
cell.
So one cell doesn't go through apoptosis.
That's not cancer in itself, but that's the first step.
The second step isn't goes into a rapid replication phase.
So cancer is a cell that doesn't go through apoptosis.
It is in rapid replication.
No, it's not one singular cell anymore.
It becomes a multiple of cells, and by the time it's diagnosed, it's millions of cells.
So those cells replicate cells that don't go through apoptosis.
So if you want to cure cancer, you have to figure out the mechanism of why that cancer
cell, those cells, are not going through apoptosis.
So learning this isn't just cold dry physiology, it's cool, interesting stuff to really help
you develop a strategy to deal with a growing cancer.
This is what chemotherapy is trying to do.
This is what radiation is trying to do.
It's trying to create apoptosis through the crisis, but we would to be able to turn on
apoptosis.
So you understand why we're learning this stuff.
If you have further questions, make sure on the upper hand left hand corner of that slide,
it says cuntersclidic.com.
That's our website.
There's a bunch of information on my website there too, and feel free to download my book.
You can find it on the website, you can find it on the button of the slide.
So just make sure you download my whole book stop fighting cancer that will help you with
this whole thing too.
You'll get on my newsletter list and you can get all this fun stuff and learn all this stuff
and I want to take care of yourself.
So the mechanisms of apoptosis, we talked about there's an extrinsic pathway and an intrinsic
pathway leading to a final common pathway.
So right now we're going to be talking about in this presentation, the extrinsic pathway.
The extrinsic pathway starts, extrinsically mean extrinsic to the cell exterior to the cell,
the cell itself of the cell membrane.
So this is a picture of the cell here.
The cell is the rounded part that's gray in this picture and this purplish double thing
on this picture is a receptor on the cell membrane.
This is a fast ligand receptor, or what's called a death receptor.
So the extrinsic pathway is receptor based, meaning there's things from the outside that
turn on the process of apoptosis from external to the cell.
So we're going to go through this really quick.
So if you really want to study this, then you're going to listen to it a few times and
dig it a little bit deeper.
But these fast receptors, they're tumor to closest factor receptors, will be stimulated by
a ligand.
A ligand is a thing that turns on a receptor.
It's kind of like a key that fits into the key hole.
The key hole is the receptor, if you want to think about that way.
So this fast receptors, tumor to closest factor receptors, will be turned on and when they
are, these receptors actually migrate together, can accumulate together.
They are proteins and they stimulate enzymes within the cell and this process is now turned
on.
The process that's turned on in this system is called the caspase system.
So it activates this caspase system that is going to lead to cellular apoptosis.
So the death receptor turns on the ligand stimulates it, turns on this receptors, the receptors
accumulate together, turns on this enzyme system called the caspase system.
Because the pro caspases are stimulated, they activate these initiator caspases, which
activate that executioner caspases, so the executioner caspases are so named because
it turns on a bunch of enzyme systems that start the cell to destroy itself from the inside
out.
This is a totally inside job now from this point on.
So once the receptor is stimulated, it turns on this process so the cell will start destroying
itself from the inside out.
The executioner caspase starts to initiate DNA aces.
So whenever you see aces at the end of any word, it is really an enzyme that will start
to devour or eat something that act, the DNA aces actually start to devour the nucleus
where the DNA is in the cell.
So it starts to devour that so it can't reproduce itself again.
That's part of the nucleus's job is in reproduction.
So with a cancer patient, the cell is going through apoptosis and there's also a nuclear issue
which is why cancer is often said to be genetic because it has that genetic component because
that nuclear reproduction of the DNA is happy very rapidly instead of about every 12 to
16 weeks.
Now it's reproducing 5 to 10 times a day.
That's what cancer is.
But if the apoptotic system is activated, this caspases, the executioner caspases will activate
DNA aces which will gobble that up and start to destroy that.
Remember, most of the nuclear components, most of the cellular components are going to
be preserved.
They're going to be conserved in apoptosis so it is really like a recycling of the cell nutrients.
So it's being gobbled up by these enzymes that then all the nuclear material and the cellular
material starts to fragment and starts to get broken down.
It causes these.
Here's a perfect picture of these little membrane blebs they're called.
So instead of being a circular cell, it starts to look start to sell, membrane starts to look
kind of weird as it starts to break apart and basically break into smaller pieces so your
white blood cells can chew them up.
That's what's called phagocytosis, your own bodies, white blood cells, typically macrophages
in the white blood cell system will be attracted to these things.
They start chewing them up.
In fact, the surfaces of these blebs actually should treat a little protein like you can
think of it like a honey that attracts the macrophages to it so they go, oh, this is tasty
yummy and they go gobble up these cells.
Now this is taking place so many times in a given hour in your body in a normal process.
The apoptosis is taking place in different cells and your macrophages are gobbling them
up and recycling the material feeding off of it and it's the way your body takes care
of them itself and recycles itself.
So the macrophages are attracted to the surfaces and they start to gobble up those apoptonic
bodies.
So the apoptonic bodies are in the pieces of the cells that are breaking off of those blebs.
This is the extrinsic pathway.
So the extrinsic pathway starts with a receptor, the receptor stimulated by a ligand, and they
are invited.
But D is a ligand in the apoptosis, that apoptosis process so it's really important as well
as some other nutrients are really important for apoptosis.
Follows through the final common pathway.
This goes on inside the cell, a whole bunch of different processes, mainly through the
caspase system, that that gobble up the DNA, gobble up the cytoplasm, that's the inner gel
of the cell, starts to gobble up the other bodies, the ribosomes, and other cellular bodies.
And the cell membrane starts to blem out and the macrophages gobble it up.
So try to fly through these slides, so if you miss that, go back and listen to it.
But stay tuned for our next presentation on 4 or 1 when we get into the intrinsic pathway.
Hopefully this was helpful.
Visit our website, call our office if you have any questions, we're always here for you.
Thanks, have a great day.